remember that you can sign up and get a
membership to the david pakman show at
joinpackman.com not only are memberships
our primary source of funding very very
important as we are now in an election
year you also get a bunch of great perks
including an extra show every day that
we do called the bonus show commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
priority access to viewer town halls and
so many other great things sign up at
joinpacman.com you can use the coupon
code wow 22 wow 22. it's an impressive
discount code okay the trump riot
committee
wants to talk to fox news propagandist
sean hannity and why wouldn't they i
mean at the end of the day this is not a
big shock sean hannity became
i don't know if we can say friend trump
doesn't really seem to have friends in
the way you or i might use the term but
he became a a colleague or associate of
donald trump's regularly talking to
donald trump and clearly was involved as
the riots and the attempts to steal the
election were going on uh the house
committee investigating the riots now
wants to talk to sean hannity and
they've released some text messages
that are stunning not in that
hannity is suggesting crazy things
but in that it makes clear that hannity
knew what was being done was a bad idea
but then he went on to tell lie after
lie after lie about the 2020 election on
his show and about the january 6 2021
riots on the program axios reporting
january 6 committee requests sean
hannity's cooperation
they have requested fox news channel
host sean hannity voluntarily
voluntarily cooperate with the
investigation hannity is one of the most
prominent media figures in america was a
close adviser to trump throughout his
presidency
the committee revealed last month that
hannity texted then white house chief of
staff mark meadows during the riot to
urge him to get trump to stop his
supporters
hannity condemned the attack on the
capital saying on his show on the night
after the riot that all of today's
perpetrators must be arrested or
prosecuted but hannity has never
criticized trump for his role in ginning
up the crowd in dc that day and he has
criticized the congressional committee
investigating january 6th article from
the daily beast
revealed sean hannity's other desperate
texts about january 6th i'm very worried
about the next 48 hours he texted mark
meadows hours before a magamob's violent
attack on the capital
we can't lose the entire white house
counsel's office hannity wrote to
meadows on december 31st 2020
i do not see january 6th happening the
way he is being told
after the sixth he should announce will
lead the nationwide effort to reform
voting integrity go to florida watch joe
mess up daily stay engaged when he
speaks people will listen
it's not terrible advice from sean
hannity
it's not what trump ultimately did but
the committee wrote to hannity that that
message quote suggests that you had
knowledge of concerns by trump's white
house counsel's office regarding the
legality of the former president's plan
for january 6th
january 5 2021 i'm very worried about
the next 48 hours the committee further
asks hannity why were you concerned
about the next 48 hours
um incredible incredible
that the public facing stuff hannity was
doing
reflected 180 degree different
perspective
on what did and was taking place than
what hannity was texting behind the
scenes same could apply to laura ingram
as we've talked about before
here is adam schiff appearing on msnbc
yesterday asked
you're looking for info and cooperation
from hannity and adam schiff says yes we
are
are you looking for information or for
cooperation from mr hannity
yes and i think you'll see an
announcement about that uh very soon um
you know we believe that he was texting
with the chief of staff
uh and that he has information that
would be relevant to our committee
he was more than a fox uh host he was
also a
confidante advisor campaigner for the
former president
and i would hope that if he's asked by
the committee as i suspect he will be
very soon that he would cooperate with
us
unclear if that will actually happen
congresswoman lofgren was also asked
about zoe lofgren asked about why
hannity and she says well we have dozens
of texts from hannity take a look at
this activity he is a fact witness we uh
have in our possession dozens of texts
that he sent to
mark meadows and others in his role as a
parent political operative
um indications of his communications
with the president and others on
strategy and it's that that we would
like to talk to him about i want to make
sure that everyone knows this isn't a
subpoena we've asked him
to cooperate with us as a fact witness
out of his sense of patriotism yeah well
good luck with that so we'll see if
hannity does show up um another very
interesting text that was uh published
by cnn's brian stelter uh highlighted by
brian stelter relatively early on quote
guys we have a clear path to land the
plane in nine days this was nine days
before
biden was sworn in he can't mention the
election ever again
ever
and clearly hannity saw
even if not out of a moral duty to say
trump's got to stop this stuff out of a
strategic duty to the republican party
hannity saying he's got to stop with the
election we can land the plane he can go
to florida criticize biden but stop
talking about the election obviously
that's not ultimately what happened and
this all makes hannity's promotion
of lies
conspiracy theories and the like even
more vile even more dishonest even more
immoral i don't expect hannity to
cooperate with the committee but let's
see if he does
even if like me you're not vegan and
you're not vegetarian eating a more
plant-based diet is a really great thing
to do for a number of different reasons
and our sponsor just egg is the
delicious plant-based egg you can use it
anywhere you use traditional eggs
because the taste and texture are
identical but
just egg plant-based eggs have the same
amount of protein as traditional eggs i
use it all the time at home
you can make fluffy scrambled eggs you
can make omelets you can make quiche
frittata crepes
fried rice you should see my fried rice
recipe you can really use it anywhere in
baking or anywhere you would use
traditional eggs when i first tried just
egg
i was surprised that a plant-based egg
could both taste and cook
just like traditional eggs you can get
it at the grocery store instacart amazon
go try it eating a more plant-based diet
is a great decision i do it and i'm not
vegan or vegetarian and just egg makes
it that much more easy and delicious